[Musique]
la flamme olympique passera par la
Réunion le 12 juin 2024 pour lancer les
prochains JO de Paris la flamme va
parcourir pendant 68 jours différents
territoires français et pour sa 29e
étape elle fera une escale d'une journée
sur notre île Saint-Paul en passant par
Saint-Pierre Saint-Joseph le tampon
Saint-Benoît Sainte-Suzanne Saint-Denis
Léo les bas toutes les communes je
dirais des différents micro territoires
par toutes les communes mais les
différentes régions seront traversées
par cette flamme le département associé
les communes la région et les acteurs du
monde sportif à cet événement la Réunion
une terre de jeu qui a déjà porté
plusieurs champions olympiques
de Séoul 88
Barcelone Atlanta Sydney Athènes
et puis on était une fois champion du
monde en 90 premier Olympia
réunionnais sportifs réunis pour
participer aux Jeux olympiques de
Montréal en 1976
et le premier Réunionnais a participé
aux JO c'est lui Jean meilleur en 1976
sur 200 mètres j'ai vu cette pléiade de
jeunes dans tous les sports mais c'est
ça veut dire que le Réunionnais c'est un
bon sens c'est un c'est un endurance
c'est un rapide c'est tout ça quoi le
jeune terre de champion aussi alors
sans relayeur porteront la flamme lors
de sa traversée de la Réunion un grand
moment de fête sportive et populaire qui
se prépare pour 2024
[Musique]